people of the internet retro reckon
sewer here and welcome back to another
animal crossing new horizons video now I
hope you guys are loving the new summer
update as much as I am one of the
questions that I have seen a lot though
online is how do I change into my
wetsuit using a one so as you guys
probably know you can use a wand once
you've unlocked one to change into
several different types of outfits now
you might think the way to do this is go
ahead and strip to completely it's your
honor right here and you go up to a
cooler or whatever wardrobe item you
prefer and I'm gonna say edit wand
outfits now for whatever reason when you
go to register a wand outfit and you try
to create an outfit you will not find
your wetsuit anywhere in the list here
it seems that the game considers the
wetsuit a separate type of item I'm
guessing that has something to do with
the fact that it actually enables you to
dive into the ocean whereas these other
items here are purely cosmetic all that
being said though guys there is a way
around this so what you'll need to do in
order to get this to work
is you'll go ahead and use the cooler or
whatever wardrobe item you prefer like I
did there and set whatever outfits you
want that don't include the wetsuit now
what you're gonna do is you're gonna
strip down completely like I am right
here and then you're gonna go and you're
gonna take your wetsuit and you're gonna
wear it now you can also put on any
other item that you want so if you have
glasses or a beard or some type of hat
so like let's just say I throw in this
sports cap item here now you you already
saw I have two wand outfits ready to go
so if I pull out my wand right here and
I go ahead and I'm just gonna change it
to my my main clothing right here retro
and you'll see that it changes into that
instantly so even though I can't set up
the wetsuit into one of those slots what
I can do is I can go and press a again
on the exact same item so I already put
on the retro Reckitt or outfit here so
if I just press a on it again it's just
going to remove the outfit and you'll
see that I revert to exactly as I was
before
now what's really cool about this is it
does not use up the item spot
so even when I change it to my retrofit
you might think okay now the wetsuits
gonna go into your inventory nope it
doesn't it's kind of like it's hidden
beneath the wand outfit that I have on
even though it's a hat and even though
it's a wetsuit it is completely hidden
and then if you see I'll just go here
again now if you don't like the Hat you
can just go ahead and remove the Hat
just like you normally would and then
you'll watch this time if I go let's go
to karate outfit I have here so we have
that and then if I go and this time I'm
just gonna say now some people may be
wondering what if you press X to revert
outfit it'll do the exact same thing
exact same thing so you can either press
X or you can just go right back to the
exact same item and press a again now
one of the problems with the ones that's
been in there since the beginning of the
game is it doesn't allow you to have
multiple items in separate categories
I'll show you what I mean here so like
my beard for example I would prefer to
have the beard on all of these now if at
any point you want to add a new wand
slot you will have to go ahead and take
off the wetsuit just like you would
normally remove any kind of clothing
here and now when I go up to it you'll
see that I can in fact access the wand
outfits now unfortunately because I have
the beard applied to this one right here
if I go and let's say I try to make a
new one down here at the bottom and I
say create outfit and I go over to wear
the beard should be it is not in here at
all and so what this means unfortunately
is that the way the ones work if you
would like to use an item in multiple
outfits you will not be able to so like
let's say that I had this crown maybe I
had two different types of shirts or
coats that I wanted to wear with the
same crown it would not let me do that
so let's say I go ahead and apply the
crown here to this one and then I don't
know let's find him out let's put him in
his bathrobe here and go ahead and hit
the plus to say done and we'll just call
this one King
now because of the fact that I have that
one set up with the crown watch what
happens if I go over here and I say
create outfit and I go where the crown
should be and you will find that it is
not here so I really hope they add that
or eventually update the game so that
you can do that because it really would
be kind of annoying to have to get
multiple items especially something like
a beard that isn't even really a
clothing item come on Nintendo we need
better than that with beards we need
better than that all right guys thanks
so much for watching hopefully this
helped you out and now you know how to
use a wand to change into your wetsuit
at least one wetsuit unfortunately you
can only do this with one wetsuit at a
time you wouldn't be able to do it with
multiple wetsuits and if this video
helped you out guys please consider
giving it a like before you go thanks so
much for watching and I'll talk to you
again soon